hi how's it going I'm back from Korea
which is wonderful and sad because I
don't see my family anymore but it's
wonderful because I'm finally back in
Los Angeles where I can actually do some
work hi hello how are you I'm good
I know it's a little late and I'm sorry
about that and I won't be too terribly
long and III just want to give over a
summary of what I've got going on in in
terms of the channel and what I've been
doing while I was in Korea and talking
about the different adventures that I
went home with my family and stuff with
that so hi hello hi everybody I was
gonna do a legitimate like stream on my
computer and I'm in my recording room
but I was like man I just don't feel
like that it's not the right vibe you
know you gotta have the right vibe when
you're making some kind of a live stream
and I just feel like this kind of
discussion is best on a couch where
you're just chilled out and relaxed and
you're not doing anything particularly
incredible how's it going it's going
good I thought I was getting sick in
fact I was getting sick and now I'm
suddenly better I don't know how it
could be the fact that when you're in
Korea you're eating a lot more
vegetables and like healthier like
things you know you're getting you're
getting some actual nutrition instead of
just eating cheesecake every night for
the past few weeks which before I left
for Korea was actually my diet I would I
would order pretty much a cheesecake
every single night Amy and I would sit
down we would watch Great British Bake
Off and then it would always make us
hungry for kind of like pastries or
desserts so we would end up ordering
some supporting cheesecake for delivery
every night and that is not a healthy
way to live so when I go over to Korea
and suddenly I'm able to eat vegetables
kimchi you know get some good rice like
all these other varieties of food
because in Korea the culture is very
much centered around food it's always
meant it was meant to be like a shared
experience food and and so they're very
serious about making sure that you are
full and I've got tons of stories about
that because my family loved to make
sure that I had food
in me times at all times of the entire
existence that I was in Korea I was full
which in Korean is called pebble oh and
you would just see me like every single
night that I was with my family the end
of it would end with me going and they
would just go peg oppa which means you
hungry and they're just like food food
you eat you eat come on you're starving
not starving there's actually a funny
story when I was um when I was it was
like the second day that I was there
probably second day and I just woken up
and I woke up before everyone else
because my clock hadn't adjusted and I
hadn't gone there long enough to be able
to get up at the right time so I was up
at like 5 a.m. and I sat in the room for
a little bit and I was like okay well no
one's awake and I don't just want to
jump out there and you know ruin and
wake everyone up and you know cuz it's
it's it's a nice sized house but it's
not a huge house so if one person is
walking out other people are gonna hear
it so I walk out there as quietly as I
can I go downstairs it's about 6:00 now
I killed some time on my phone and I
walked downstairs creeping this as
gently as I can and a lot of Koreans
especially without a number of family in
the in the house that they were sleeping
on the floor so they were sleeping on
the floor on the upstairs they were
sleeping on the floor downstairs and
then everyone else had their rooms that
they could have had oh well thank you
demanded love thank you I I'm happy to
be back thank you so much for that but
no need no need stop that stop that yes
so um I'm creeping down as much as I can
creep I'm creeping as quietly as hushed
as I can and I get down to the bottom
and I'm like I'm a little hungry but I
don't want to tell anybody that I'm
hungry because then that's gonna get the
throngs of people out so I quietly sneak
into the kitchen I grab a bowl and I'm
bout to get some rice but the problem
with this rice cooker is that it has a
lock unlock mechanism it's made by some
company called Kaku which is kind of
ironic because this was the clarion call
that woke up everybody in the house so
KooKoo it's it's simple as a little
rooster and when you unlock it it goes
due to date like a very loud beeping
delete so I like butta deep ah [ __ ]
but I didn't hear anybody so I thought I
was in the clear so I pop it open cook
trunk
grab the rice paddle i scoops him out
for myself and I'm like okay I made it
little clacking of the the chopsticks
and I go out into the living room like
okay I'm good I just sit down I grab
some Kim some fried from some fried
seaweed and I was like I can eat this in
peace and no one's gonna bother me but
then a door squeaks suddenly and my aunt
who it's so funny because they never
refer to each other as their names it's
always different like different like
like nicknames first for someone that's
that's like their koey aunt in korean is
emo so emo i am oh would be like the
most direct translation not necessarily
emo like emo emo but emo so I forget
what nickname this emo was but it was uh
I believe it was the eldest of my mom's
sister so the oldest of my aunts and she
just rounds the corner just sticks her
head like the door the door squeaks open
and I just see her head pop out from
like the crack there and she's just like
peg oppa she's like and I'm like oh yeah
but I'm good I got I got my rice I'm
good
Peggle pie if you didn't remember means
hungry she's just like bag oppa and that
was the siren call that woke up my
entire family because I have six aunts
at the time only four of them were in
the house and my mother were there but
then upstairs you hear another door
opens some steps there's a railing above
there and just I see a head peering over
the railing just like Peggle other just
looks definitely like peg oppa and I'm
like no no I'm good and she's like oh
yeah sit down sit down sit down
she comes down the stairs then my other
aunt comes out of the other Emily Oh
pick up ah oh okay and then my mom comes
out of the bathroom because apparently
she was in there the whole night and I
don't know why but my mom goes Oh pick
up Oh mark you hungry you should have
told me it was like Oh God hugger I have
rice and then instantly everyone just
started piling food in the living room
table like just it was a small table
it's kind of customary to sit on the
floor when you eat in Korea so I was a
sitting on the floor and it was this low
coffee table style thing and just food
food
kimchi bean sprouts fish squid a like
soup
suddenly there was soups for breakfast
out of everywhere it was just tons and
tons of stuff and just food food food
food food and I'm just like it was it
was 6:00 in the morning and then
suddenly 7:00 in the morning and I'm
just pebble oh oh god I'm so full
anymore I can't possibly eat anymore
and then just like constantly that was
every day every single day I was in
Korea it was just a series of pega pega
pop and then when we weren't cooking in
the house we were going out to eat at
all these different restaurants that we
were go to and restaurants like in Korea
very reasonable very reasonable except
for one but that's another story that
I'll get to later but it was a great
time and this is the first time in a
long time that I was actually able to
talk with my family like I was I'd been
learning Korean for about a year not
that it did me that much good when I was
over there but it did me a considerable
amount of good because number one I can
read it now and number two I understand
the grammar so I know what they're
trying to get at when they are saying
something my vocab is just way way way
way way low compared to actual
conversational but as once I start
learning the words and I'm learning
words as I go along I will get to the
point where I can be conversational and
that will that will like literally be
game-changing because I was able to
communicate number one the person I
communicated with the most was my cousin
hyung Bay who you guys saw in the did
you guys see the the Korean candy video
my cousin hyeong BAE is the tall one so
he's he's the tallest
Bunch he's uh this is really really
funny guy also he's trying to be an
actor over in Korea and he's been in a
few cool roles so if anyone's watching
this from Korea and you need an actor
for your show
call up young BAE he's got great
headshots he's very yep Buddha and he
told me that was not the right word but
I'm like I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
that that man very yep Buddha yeah young
BAE young BAE is like I've known hyung
BAE forever and I've never talked to
hyung BAE before I've known him since I
was six years old maybe even younger
than that maybe I went over there when I
was like four I can't remember exactly
when those pictures that I showed during
the the candy video those were so long
ago that I have no memory of the actual
event so maybe it was even before that
like it was it was hello do not disturb
while driving or do you think I'm
driving phone I'm not okay I'm back now
yeah that was so long ago that I don't
remember it and hyung BAE has been a
part of my life that entire time and the
most mind-blowing thing is I've never
spoken to him never once actually spoken
to him in a way that we could understand
each other I visited and every time that
I visited I've hung out with him
I really have but I've never spoken to
him and so to have a situation where you
have a family member who's been involved
in your life for so long and he's he's a
kind of guy that knows like what I'm
doing he knows what I'm doing he knows
incredibly what I'm doing oh thank you
so much to Evan eight six two three you
guys if you if you can whenever someone
does something like that give a uber
chat or becomes a member of the channel
you can actually type in chat at their
name just type the @ symbol and then put
in like there was a recent super chat
from terrific T Orr just at and their
name it shows up and it highlights for
them so it makes it really special for
them too so if you guys can help out
anytime something like that happens just
hit the hippie at symbol start typing
their name and and just give them a warm
welcome
like in
big thank you for that because I really
appreciate that you don't need to give
me any super chat everybody who's a
member of the channel thank you so much
I really appreciate it so if you guys
see that and I don't see it definitely
give them the right of recognition that
they deserve so but with my cousin hyung
BAE and this is kind of something that I
I almost regret for long like a big part
of my life is the fact that this person
this hilarious hilarious person I've got
so many sort I've actually I've got a
list we got a list of notes that I have
just to talk about all of the different
things that uh that we did in Korea that
I have to tell stories for and I've
barely gotten through the first one the
first story I had written down was
literally just emos asking peg oppa and
I've got car repair shop jam session at
youngbae's father's garage massage at
bath house where I was straddled by a
man a really good massage and a scrub
down - that's another story where we
carried grandma to her wheelchair we
went to Lookout we went to the old
palace grounds Museum Korean man in
small restaurants said I looked French
that's literally a notation I have yer
haggled in Seoul for clothes I ate a
chicken foot which was just not good in
any capacity the packed market the not
so one-way road that young took us down
we almost died herb island which is a
wonderful place and a grocery store
man yelling about fish and meat I talked
about in the Korean candy video I've got
so many stories here that I want to get
through and I've only managed to get
through one so I'm never going to be
able to get through all of them until I
get to get through this but just um what
I'm saying is young BAE is an absolutely
hilarious guy and I knew just enough
Korean to talk to him and he knew just
enough English to talk to me that we
could bridge the gap and we could talk
to each other in this weird broken way
but where we could fully understand each
other and where he could make me laugh
unbelievably and I can make him laugh
and it was just like this this this this
thing that I've been missing out on my
entire
life this whole side of my family that I
haven't been able to connect with this
whole side of me that I've been denying
my whole life because I I've talked
about this before No thank you so much
Wolfie to gamer but there's no honestly
no need for that dude no need for that
that's really like I thank you but no
please don't give it to someone that
actually deserves it but this this whole
side of me when I was growing up the the
Korean side the the Asian side the side
that would get made fun of when I was a
kid you know and it's not because you
know all these kids that I grew up with
were horribly racist this is like their
kids if there's anything about you
that's different kids pointed out kids
try to isolate the people that are
different and so me trying to survive as
a kid and just rationalizing I started
to kind of not embrace the Korean side
of me I I started to push myself
actively away from like Korean culture
stuff like that I didn't have an
interest in learning the great pineapple
ten dollars in case you're hungry I'm
good I'm good that was that was young
his favorite slogan just although I'm
good I good I good I'm good no no worry
it okay it okay and I taught him the the
awesome phrase don't worry about it
which he used every time he usually it
made me laugh because it was so you just
he's every time because I told him it
was a very fancy way of saying like oh
it's okay it's like I told me that like
if you say don't worry about it all sexy
like you know it's it's very charming
it's a very polite way of saying you
know don't it's okay but so every time
he'd say it it going deeper and deeper
don't worry I'd do anything I hope I
like open the door for him he's like oh
thank you think but when I was a kid
like this this guy every time I would go
back to Korea I've never try you know I
would never try to communicate I would
never try because
the shitty kid that I was being taken
halfway across the world which is
something that people don't just get to
do and they definitely don't just get to
be welcomed in in the way where all of
my family was always so happy to see me
every single one of my family members
was always before I did YouTube when I
was just a baby when I was as a kid when
I was a shitty teenager they were always
always happy to see me welcoming warm
and they invited me into their home this
barely recognizable member of their
family they were so happy to see me and
they invited me in and I being the
shitty kid that I did didn't think
anything of it and so this has been the
first time that I was able to really
appreciate it like really truly honestly
appreciated and it made me realize like
a lot of things and and and I'm not
saying I got some grand enlightenment
out of it but one of the things that I
like really thought about when I was
there was just the fact that I waste a
lot of time like worrying about things
that don't matter
trying to find an easy way through doing
something and try that trying to think
about all the ways that it could go
wrong when in reality one of the
greatest things that like you could do
is just jumping in like feet first both
feet jumping and diving into something
that you want to do kind of like the
this this idea of kind of sucking it up
and I'm not saying sucking it up
emotionally but sucking it up when
there's something that you want and what
I wanted was like when I first started
to learn Korean as like I wanted to
learn Korean so I could talk to my
family but I didn't realize that was
leading me down this road of a deeper
connection with who I am like really
honestly truly this connection with who
I am as a person and so when it came
down to this possibility where I could
go and see my family and stuff like this
oh my god Oh what is that Ashlee's
beautiful craziness love you Markie mu
I'm more than happy to give you this
much you've saved my life and you made
me laugh when no one else could thank
you so much for being my best friend
this is the least I can do to pay you
back for what you've done for me much
love oh thank you so much for that but
there's no need
thank you I'm good though thank you oh
that's too nice everybody please thank
everybody that's been giving stuff
because I know I miss stuff and I feel
terrible about that but it's it's really
something that means the world to me
like I'll get back to what I was saying
before but one of the cool things like I
mentioned before was that because of the
membership system I'm now able to
release the the Tor special next Friday
next Friday that's coming out I'm
finishing up the last edits on it and
I'm gonna do the premiere system of it
so we can all watch it at the same time
live it's long it's long it's like
feature-length long it's it's clocking
at about 70 minutes but we'll be able to
watch it all next Friday probably normal
release time probably next Friday 11:00
and Pacific time I may push it forward
just a bit just in case people are in
school and they want to see you live but
then we all can watch it together and I
can chat with you guys and you can chat
with me but that's gonna be next Friday
or let's say it's gonna be one ish I
don't know I'll ask you guys what its
gonna be like but just yeah thank you
thank you everybody that's supported the
channel through memberships and stuff
like that and everybody that's been
giving like this it's ridiculous god
someone else did
Alisha Raven thank you so much and but
what I was saying is when I when I set
out to do that and when I set out to do
what I wanted to do like I didn't know
how to do it so I came up with a lot of
like different schemes to try to do it
better or easier or try to find the
right way to do it or or try to think
about you know the the the the fastest
way to learn Korean so that I wouldn't
waste my time and and what it comes down
to and what I realized is like there's a
lot of things in life there's the adage
of work hard work smarter not harder but
in the vast majority of life you just
got to put your nose to the grindstone
you gotta do until it's done like that
is the biggest lesson that you can learn
because there isn't always a shortcut
and especially when it comes down to
language learning there is no shortcut
oh sure you can get like this system
versus that system but at the end of the
day if you want to talk to people you
got a number one know the words number
two know the grammar and number three
most important of all just [ __ ] talk
to people
there's so many people in language
learning circles that are like I want to
learn language but I'm scared to talk to
people that's how you learn the language
how do you think a baby does it a baby
does it because they're trying so
unbelievably desperately to talk to
people like that is Bar None if you want
to learn a language you got to talk to
people because I learned more in the two
weeks that I was in Korea than I ever
did in all of the the the vast majority
of year-long learning that I'd done
because I was struggling to talk to
people and your brain trying to figure
that [ __ ] out is what naturally makes
you able to talk to people if you want
to learn talk to people that's the only
thing you got to do and that applies to
a lot things that extend farther beyond
just what's like just language learning
it extends to things outside of language
learning is stents the things that you
want like if you want YouTube you know
what you got to do make videos you got
to make videos and you got to try harder
and you got to market yourself and get a
talk to people you got to make it work
for you you got to do everything if you
want something in life sometimes they're
just not an easy road I've talked about
this before in terms of just like
sometimes if you want something and the
road is paved with broken glass you
gotta take off your shoes and you gotta
cut up your feet and walk and every
steps gonna suck it's gonna be agony
it's gonna be painful and you're gonna
hate every step of it but at the end of
the day that's the only road to get
where you want to get it maybe along the
way you'll find a little path that's not
so covered in glass and maybe maybe
maybe occasionally you'll get to put on
like one one shoe on one foot and you'll
hobble along at the end of the day look
if you want something like you really
want something you got to go for it
and that's kind of like what I'm seeing
now like if I if I want something and me
and in the grand scheme that I am like
you're always trying to find ways to
improve myself you know it's it's it's
nice because there's also this part of
me that always wants to rush things you
know always wants to have things now and
always
to you know have instant gratification
and I think a lot of people like that am
I constantly cutting off my head when
I'm talking I have no idea I'm not even
looking at the camera but there's so
many different like things that you know
I want and some things just take time
you know you can't have everything in a
day you can't have everything like
immediately some things you have to do
in a way you're chipping away at it like
day by day you're just chipping away one
single day at a time making progress
that's so insignificant that it seems
imperceptible you know making progress
that seems like you're not actually
doing anything but in reality you're
taking a step that someone else is
you're taking a step that someone else
wouldn't and you're doing something that
someone isn't and those little itty
bitty insert imperceptible amounts of
change add up to improving yourself
learning a language making more videos
extending farther beyond learning a new
skill like meeting new people these
small small small victories tiny
insignificant seeming victories are the
only thing to get to you word but get
you where you want to go and anyway so
what I was saying was this trip was
great for me because it helped me
realize like a big part of who I am you
know it's it's not like it's not like I
want to try to embrace that side of me
that is me like the the side of me that
I I see when I'm in Korea and the side
that I'm finally starting to appreciate
that's that's not that is me it's half
of me it's half of Who I am and I just
want to know more and I and it was never
true here's a here's another story it
was never truer then when I was in the
temple where my grandfather's headstone
is it's not really a headstone in the
sense that there's a grave in this
temple it's really it's a really
fascinating place it's hard to describe
in words but it's basically a Buddhist
temple that
is a shrine for these small wooden
plaques that are inscribed with the
names of the family and just like brief
information about you know when they
died and stuff like that and when we
went in that temple I've been there
before that's the thing I was there when
my grandpa was buried or not buried when
he was cremated I was there when he was
cremated I was there at the temple
before and being there then compared to
being there now was night and day and I
have no idea why because I was walking
the same steps that I walked before I
was in the same area that I was before I
was seeing the same things that I was
before but through completely different
eyes this time because the impact of it
when when my grandpa died and and my
grandpa again is someone that I didn't
connect with I connected with him more
than my other members of my family
because he actually spoke some English a
good bit of English that's how that's
how he knew my dad and that's how my dad
met my mom was through my grandpa and
when he passed and I was back there you
know even then I didn't really
appreciate it but I started to get some
nuance about it but this time around it
was completely different you know cuz we
were there with my Graham my grandma and
my grandma is my last living grandparent
the only one I have left and you know
she I don't know how many years she has
left to be perfectly honest she's had
two strokes now and I'm pretty sure
she's showing the early signs of
Alzheimer's and she it was heartbreaking
at the same time as really a weird
sensation because every time that I
would see her every single day when I
would wake up and I would go downstairs
and I would see my grandma she wouldn't
know who I was she would keep asking
like who is this guy who was this guy
and I would understand her to the extent
that I knew she was asking who I was and
I would try to explain to her in Korean
like it like I'm your grandson like I'm
the same kid that you saw when I was
just very young she she only really
remembers me
from before she had her stroke and so
she remembers me as this tiny child and
so every morning she was shocked because
she was like who's man who's this man
and she would get shocked and she would
see me and she'd be like oh my god you
know you were this tiny kid
you were this tiny kid and now you're so
big like you've grown up and and she
would like get emotional every single
morning and like I said that was it was
both heartbreaking and heartwarming
because like it it was what I wanted I
knew that me connecting with my grandma
you know he wasn't going to be perfect
because like again I don't know how much
time she has left I don't know how much
time I had left to talk with her and I
was actually able to talk with her and
every single day I was able to
reintroduce myself to her and I was able
to reintroduce myself to her better than
I did the day before because I was
learning more as I was going and I was
looking up online like different words
to say who I was different ways to say
who I was I was asking my mom did say
different like how do I introduce myself
better to my grandma and so my grandma
was there when we went back to the
temple to pay respects to my grandpa my
grandfather and it was the first time
that I actually participated in the in
the ceremony behind the lighting of the
incense the the bowing three times the
pouring of the tea the the whole the
whole thing that I've never really taken
an appreciation but like loved before
and it was it was good it was nice it
was it was good to see like this this
this kind of connecting of the culture
for Korea because we brought food like
we brought food to the temple number one
to donate to the temple but also just
like we brought some of my grandpa's
favorite food which oddly enough is this
spicy cup ramen this instant you pour
hot water in ramen and it's this ramen
this spicy ramen that I love like like
to this day it's what I what I ate as a
kid it's what I ate you know as like
just as young young kid
and I didn't know that like I didn't
know that's how far it went like with me
in my life this this ramen that I ate
was my grandpa's favorite ramen and we
brought a case of it into the temple and
laid it at his at his little headstone
there and we paid respect to the
headstone altogether you know we
remembered like who he was and my family
was able to tell me about him a little
more and I was able to learn a little
more about myself and a little more
about my like my culture and a little
more about like where I came from
because I don't know I I probably told
this story before but I don't know if
I've told it in the same way I I'm not
sure what the brand name is I can't
remember what it's called it's it's a
pretty popular ramen in Korea it's a red
cup Isaac called nobody I can't remember
it's a red cup with some black lettering
it's pretty popular in Korea somebody in
chat could probably point it out to me
but I don't know if I've ever really
explained this story about how my family
kind of came to be because it's a weird
weird weird string of coincidences that
led me to be even here
my grandfather had family up in North
Korea and I'm probably not gonna be a
hundred percent accurate with this
because obviously this has been told and
translated to be before but the general
point of it is before the Korean War my
grandfather along with his wife my
grandmother and I believe maybe a
brother and his brother's wife they were
in North Korea before North Korea was
even North Korea up near the Chinese
border and before war broke out he knew
either from someone in the American
military or someone related to that he
knew that [ __ ] was about to go down and
he had to make a choice he was told that
this is going to be bad and he had to
flee South no matter what things were
gonna go bad war
was about to break out and he had to go
south and so my grandpa talked to his
many family members as he could and said
I need to leave and he's 19 at the time
I'm pretty sure this was when he was 19
years old just married like no kids yet
had to go left left behind everything
because he talked to his family and his
family didn't want to go his parents
didn't want to go you know the rest of
his family didn't want to go some lot of
his friends didn't want to go he and my
grandma ran down south they hitched
rides they took the train they went
south and they got into Seoul with very
little time before war actually broke
out and so they made it south just in
time and as far as I know he never saw
any of his family ever again because
when war broke out and the line went
down and and then the truce was made
North Korea was shut off this is in the
1950s or 1960s or whatever it is the
very beginning of it and he never saw
anyone that he knew growing up ever
again
and so he started a new life down in
South Korea he started he started just
all over again he didn't have much money
you know it's not like Korea was doing
wonderfully after the war ended so he
had to make do with what he had he and
my grandma basically scraped and saved
as much money as they could they saved
every single penny that they possibly
could you know they started a family
they had my oldest son they had a few
wants they kept trying for a boy they
kept trying for a boy they never got a
boy so I ended up with seven on so they
had seven daughters and then after the
seventh one they were just like okay I
guess you know we're just not gonna have
a son I'm just like we're gonna end it
there
you know seven kids that's enough and so
my seven aunts you know they grew up and
then in in my grandpa was working with
the American army and so he in working
with the American army met my dad my dad
through my grandpa met my mom and then a
couple years later or many years later I
was born and I wasn't planned no no no I
was not I was not a planned baby I was
not supposed to have it my brother was
born and then my parents were like
that's enough ones enough for now and
then I just happened to be here
and it's that crazy string of events
that somehow led to me existing in the
first place you know I wouldn't be here
if my grandpa didn't decide that he
needed to run if he if he he could have
easily made the decision not to go
because like frankly like that's what a
lot of his family was saying like why
should we go why why we have stuff here
we have money we have land we have stuff
here and he left
and without that decision I wouldn't be
here you know they they tried for a they
tried for a son you know maybe maybe
four they had a son after the second
child because my mom was the middle
child she was the fourth kid one two
three four yeah she was the fourth kid
May if they had a son after that third
the second even the fourth one if that
was a son ty wouldn't be here that would
be it for me like I wouldn't be here and
then you know if my my grandpa hadn't
just so happened to been working in the
army and that my dad my dad was
introduced so the rest of their family
now my mom wouldn't be here you know
it's uh yeah it's it's just a weird
story so when we were in the temple and
you know we were paying respect to this
and we were seeing like the effect that
this had on my family and the big family
and I think I I think I just posted the
the picture of me with my family at the
temple I believe I did did I maybe I did
maybe I didn't I have no idea did I that
I can't even remember what I've done I
think I've posted it on Instagram did I
yeah I did okay I posted it over on
Instagram it's the picture of me with my
grandma up in the temple and
you know that was those really special
that was like the third or fourth day
that was after the whole Peck upon
incident but you know seeing that temple
again seeing how little had changed in
that place in the over ten years since
I'd been there before I think it'd been
15 years 15 years since I was last there
and I remembered it like I remembered
every part of it every step I remembered
the the three like different shrines
that they had there are more the stairs
up I remembered that statue and there
was some obviously they cleaned it up
and they they kept it nice but I
remembered it but I definitely didn't
remember having any sort of reverence
for it I definitely didn't remember
having any sort of respect for it and
stuff like that so yeah it was an
incredibly important experience for me
and I can't describe in words how much I
encourage you guys to connect with who
you are
and your story is probably not going to
be the same as my story your story is
probably not going to be something where
you can go see family who are so eager
to teach you about you're who you are
and your history or maybe even you don't
have family to go for but that that's
not the main point from all this the
main point the main takeaway is that
we're all very slowly and day-by-day
learning who we are as people
I am very slowly very steadily learning
Who I am as a person YouTube has been my
journey into learning Who I am you know
my life has been a journey in learning
Who I am learning what I can do learning
what I'm capable of pushing past the
moments where I think I'm only capable
of so much and extending that and
calling myself an idiot for even
thinking that I had reached my
limitations or had taken for granted
what I have and you know not accepting
who I was
and you know I would encourage everybody
to do whatever it takes to figure out
who you are as a person self-discovery
is the most important thing that we
could ever do self-improvement
self-discovery trying new things
learning new experiences and seeing
ourselves reflected in the eyes of the
people that we meet you know those are
important those moments that we have are
important and the only way that we can
keep going in life is to keep trying new
things until you can see a clearer
picture of who you are and yeah that's
very important
oh no I'm I'm uh I'm back in back in the
u.s. time by now but anyway so I I want
to I want to get past this because I
could talk for days and days how much
this affected me and I can talk for days
of days how much any of this encouraged
me to want to do more stuff and I could
talk for days and days about how
important this has been for me in my
family but I want to get to these
stories because I've only told one story
two stories now because I want I did
want to talk about going to the temple
but I'll give you a choice okay I'll
give you a choice I can either talk
about the massage I had at the bath
house which if any of you know about
Korean bath houses you know that they're
very naked uh Koreans boy they like to
get naked and boy they love them some
bath houses so I can talk about that I
can talk about how I ate a chicken foot
I could tikkun foot that's it's not a
long story but that's an interesting
story or I can talk about herb island
the greatest theme park in the history
of the universe the absolute pinnacle of
theme parks ever herb island is the
great I learned so much
herb lure at herb island so there's herb
island there's me eating and chicken
foot or me getting a massage at the bath
house what whoa would you like how about
all those stories you get one you get
one I don't want to go on too long
tonight so you get one yeah I don't want
to waste your time but each of these
stories is a good
good story good story so I can't do a
poll so you just got a shout and chat as
much as you can as to which one you want
so keep just blasting it out and I'll
see which one that I can get bathhouse
amusement park herb Island massage theme
park herb-lore whoo bathhouse it's
pretty split it's pretty split a lot of
people seem to want to know about herb
island but okay now I'm seeing a bunch
of bathhouse oh now I'm seeing massage
now I'm seeing Island Oh No
this is pretty split I may have to Oh
God okay I'm gonna flip a coin okay it
seems really split at least people don't
seem to want to know about the chicken
foot so that'll be I'll tell the chicken
foot story afterwards but I've got this
um I've got this half dollar on a flip
it will say heads for eventually like
overtime I'll tell both of them but I'm
only gonna tell one more for tonight um
we'll say heads for the massage story
tails for herb island okay sounds fair
okay here we go
don't betray the herb I would never
okay what did I say well those tails
again cuz it was tails tails loser herb
island I think
I think it's fine anyway what was it
herb Island you're meant to tell both
and we'll see what happens okay
tails observe island okay so herb island
oh sit down buckle up get some popcorn
herb Island is about to blow your
[ __ ] socks off and I have got
pictures to back it up okay so alright
you buckled up oh you better be buckle
up if you're paying attention to my
Instagram story which apparently I
started using once again you would have
seen some cool features from herb island
that the likes of which you've never
ever ever even dared to imagine Oh go
somewhere quiet because you're about to
scream your head off about how you were
not able to go to herb island that I was
you're gonna be so incredibly jealous of
all the amazing things that I've seen at
EV island that you did not see her boy I
hope I'm building it I hope I'm not over
hyping it because there really is no
overhyping this thing okay so I don't
have a picture of it but imagine you're
driving up this mountain it's a nun
seaming Mountain and I mean really
imagine it okay shut your eyes everybody
collectively shut your eyes you're gonna
need to shut your eyes are you closed
your eyes klar you closed why are you
closed are you closed now imagine you're
driving up in the mountains you're in
the backseat of your relatives car that
you can barely talk to you don't know
where you're going because you couldn't
even communicate where the location
would be and even if they said it you
wouldn't know where it was because you
don't understand the country and you're
bad at geography but you're driving up
in these mountains bumpy road rustling
you around and around in this rickety
old car that you're not sure when where
why or when it was made but you stopped
you stopped
pay this ticket man this happy-looking
ticket ma'am and in a oddly military
looking uniform with an assault rifle
with a big gun but he saw you
you pay the man in a strange foreign
currency that you don't understand and
you drive up this hill and has to you
crest over the hill open your eyes open
your eyes you see a 20 foot tall statue
of a wizard shooting his magic beyond
into your eyes welcoming you to
Island oh yes it is the herb wizard and
he is beautiful you look to your left
herbs you look to your right herbs herbs
herbs herbs no matter where you are no
matter what you do you open the windows
of the car oh the pungent smell of
rosemary who set some oregano over there
oh just the tantalizing tastes of herb
Island and you haven't even parked yet
so close your eyes again close close
close them because you dare not look at
the herb wizard his eyes follow you as
your car passes by so you avert your
gaze as best you can but you know
piercing in your mind you can see the
wizard is warm welcoming aura welcoming
you different you park very haphazardly
because in Korea apparently parking lots
are a free-for-all
so you park very haphazardly you open
the door you get out and you see
infinite possibility and so infinite
possibility infinity he starts out with
these these really lovely cartoon
characters tootin their duders just a
boo - they don't actually play music but
you can hear it in your soul here's
another one just a dancing fool and
that's just the start
because then this friendly looking guy
who I am absolutely a hundred percent
unsure of what origin like this person
is supposed to be they were outside of
it
so I think they were supposed to be
Native American but it was in Korea so
and he looks vaguely Asian but he's
wearing caveman outfit this guy was just
confusing no idea what this was supposed
to be but welcoming nonetheless you can
feel the warm aura coming from within
yeah Oh for some reason I took a video
of that but I think the confusion is
just meant to throw you off because then
there's this guy there's this guy who is
right next to that guy so this is what
really threw me off because this guy is
very clearly Native American with uh
kind of like a bandana holding what
seems to be a paintbrush and his face
looks extremely Korean so already I
think it's all just designed close your
eyes again and close shut them close
don't talk don't speak let me speak I
think what it is is it's supposed to
disorient you because you're about to
enter the greenhouse oh yes this is
where they grow every herb known to man
close your eyes you're not supposed to
see any of this close your eyes have you
ever seen rosemary right up close and
personal have you ever seen a pollen
then when you rub its leaf and smell
your fingers
smells like lemonade have you ever seen
that no no you have not your brain
wouldn't be able to handle it so these
confusing statues were there put there
to put you in a state of confusion so
you wouldn't think too deeply about
close your eyes you're not supposed to
say this close your eyes and you know
you know that's the only thing that
saved you from destruction okay moving
on okay next time in the story let me
just I'm just gonna flip through this
because I have no idea what's going on
and I've got probably too many pictures
of Amy so I'm going to avoid those so
just I was I was unbelievably winded
from my adventure so immediately I had
to take I had to take a nice a nice
break on this lovingly place bench and
okay I'm being ridiculous but also this
place was goddamn beautiful this place
was [ __ ] gorgeous here's young-bae
look at him look at him look at
young-bae yeah so goddamn handsome ah
look at him yes what am i Anna what a
man wait ya-ha-hoo ladies he's single
all right oh oh this is my aunt she
would hate me if I showed this picture
and I'm showing this picture but that's
my aunt she's she was what she was doing
is she was rubbing the plant that I was
telling you about that if you rub your
fingers on it and smell it smells like
either lemonade or like there's a whole
bunch of different ones it was one that
was like strawberries or something I
think and so are any of these live
photos now they're not okay so oh also
um I guess Tigger was there and piglet
although cast of Winnie the Pooh which
I'm sure I'm sure that's a nice picture
I like that picture anyway pictures yeah
there we go
oh look at that just uh sure yeah I'm
sure perfectly licensed absolutely
totally legally allowed piglet trying to
try it try it try to charm Amy over
there yeah anyway so we go back here and
then just so one of my favorite pictures
that I took while I was there it's
actually this one I I really really
really like this picture and no no
joking no sarcasm I really like this
picture anyway I just think it's a good
picture
and then I took a bunch more selfies and
then literally just like herbs herbs
herbs herbs herbs okay close your eyes
again close your eyes again close your
eyes again it's about to get sensual in
here it's about to get sensual close
your eyes you're not supposed to see I
don't cover that look cover the screen
because you guys I can't trust you not
to close your okay close your eyes
all right you seeing that okay you
thinking it you feel in it okay you've
just entered into the herb zone and
you're like Oh ABS herbs herbs I can't
get enough of these herbs I can't get
enough of herbs in my life
herb Island is just too much for me to
ever even remotely try to endure but
then once you think you've had enough of
herb Island oh you had no idea that it
extended far beyond anything that your
wildest dreams could possibly ever hope
to imagine because what I'm about to
show you is a world more magical more
amazing than you could ever dream of now
open your eyes
[Music]
I took I took so many videos like that I
took so many videos like that that were
just [ __ ] terrible terrible terrible
I took so many [ __ ] terrible videos
but okay so there's that and then like
there's so then we entered Santa world
filled with purple Santa's I didn't know
why but we didn't go in dear world just
yet we went we went we took a detour
okay so herb island let me let me put
this to you straight her violin not only
had saniland and I call it Santa land
because it wasn't Christmas land no it
was Santa land it was Santa land and in
Santa land
Santa rained there was only one statue
of mrs. Claus anywhere but we haven't
even gotten to that it close your eyes
again close your eyes close your eyes
now you've seen herbs right close your
eyes close your eyes imagine you
remember you just came out of herb
forest the greenhouse so many smells
assaulted your nostrils you're not
supposed to see this close your eyes
what do you think you're gonna see next
you see a little taste of Santa but you
are not prepared for what comes next
because just guess say out loud it
wherever you are close your eyes you're
not supposed to see this close your eyes
say out loud what you think is around
the next corner you've seen herbs you've
seen Santa you've seen a strange Native
American at the very opening of this and
you've seen the herb wizard what do you
think is next
what do you think is next close your
eyes open your eyes what do you think's
next unless you guessed dinosaurs
his dinosaur let me tell you I've never
known I needed a park like this until
this very moment because and doggies
doggies I posted this on opposing this
on on on my story but here you go
donkeys a dollar-for-dollar get a bowl
of carrots and feed up to these doggies
cuz and then it was a zoo and and also
they had they had like they had like
chicken in the zoo the chickens and they
had tiny pigs which were very cute and
then they had a peacock so it was a
great zoo it was best suit I've ever
seen and I didn't get a video of it but
there was these these little animatronic
dinosaurs that a kid rode in it was like
tiny baby was on top of it over
weirdest thing I've ever seen but it
felt so natural also got this video
which is my favorite and then then then
we went to Santa world so I got this
other video which is a great I'm very
proud of that one oh also this video
okay anyway so I've got snap seven
confirmed yeah for NASA seven the pre
prequel back in time when dinosaurs were
there bang anyway getting out of myself
hey I know myself so uh where is show
your ass show your eyes share your eyes
do you imagine the one thing that could
complete this experience for you the one
thing that would summarize close your
eyes you're not supposed to see this
close your eyes imagine the one thing
that would complement this entire
experience bring together the herbs
bring together the Santa's bring
together the dinosaurs the one thing the
one thing that would unite it all and
what is that think it think it close
your eyes you're not supposed to do this
think it think it hard think it fast and
let's all say it at the same time
are you ready three two one belly
dancers I don't have a video of it
because it felt like it would have been
weird if I were to film the belly
dancers but you around the corner out of
the greenhouse you go down to a lake
that looks like Disneyland Pirates of
the Caribbean little lake there and then
we're belly dancers they were both
dancers just dance around those like
kids it's this is kids parents like
adults every every age and there was
just like barely closed belly dancer
just like really gyrating i mean if ever
there was a word to describe the action
of this lady gyration is the only word
that springs to mind does lightning
speed of the hip movement like just
absolutely thunderously gyrating left
right up down back forth all six
directions plus a few in the fourth
dimension like this woman was moving and
then when she was done three other women
came out of nowhere and just started
gyrating and I couldn't make direct eye
contact for fear that the wizard that I
can now see would judge me and so I
didn't take any video of the women
gyrating but it happened at herb island
so at this point my entire existence was
shattered thrice over and I could barely
contain the joy inside my soul at the
experience that herb island gave to me
and so with a heavy heart and a heavy
bladder the family and I gathered up hit
the bathroom and then moved on back to
the car where we settled in and began
our journey home but I tell you this and
close your eyes close your eyes close
your eyes close your eyes tight and
imagine this you're crammed back in the
backseat of that rickety car that you
don't know what year it was made and you
don't even think it was ever made in a
year and you start driving and moving
over the many many speed bumps that they
have and he waved goodbye close your
eyes you're not supposed to see is he
waved goodbye to the herb wizard and
believe me when I tell you he winked
waved and cast a spell good luck upon me
it's true it's true 100% true 100% fact
true definition of truth it happened
you felt it for those of you who closed
your eyes it happened and you felt it I
know I was there and I felt the joy of
her her bile and carry with me that was
on the second day second day that we
were in Korea we were blessed in herb
island and no other day lived up to that
day so I want you to remember that I
want you to remember the joy for her
violent carry that with you in your
heart as you go home you feel it oh you
feel it the herb-lore coursing through
your veins
the herblore penetrating your mind the
herb-lore taking you to places you could
never know before also they had tons of
weed there so that was nice too
anyway so that is the herb Island story
that's about it I don't think I think
I've made my way through three stories
of my twenty that I have written there's
so many different stories here but I'm
gonna I'm gonna leave it there for now
I'm just gonna leave it there for now
the other thing I'm gonna say is I am
super excited to be back to me making
videos again to like do cool stuff to
learn new things to try any things and
I'm super super excited because I have
this chance and you guys do too and
listen I'll wrap it up real quick here I
promise I won't keep you very long but
listen close to this one because this
really does matter a lot to me what I
what I've done like in terms of making
videos on YouTube and making content for
you guys and learning about myself a lot
of this journey that I've done has been
life-changing you know everything that
I've done on YouTube and everything that
I've done you know in life and
everything that I've you know every
opportunity that I have to better myself
and improve the situations of those who
are around me in
and like extend some goodwill out into
the community there because I took this
chance to learn something about myself
when I started YouTube I did it because
I didn't like who I was but I didn't
like who I was because I didn't
understand who I was I didn't see the
potential inside of me you know you you
form who you are in the experiences that
you go through and if you play your life
safe and you play your life without
taking risks without learning more about
yourself without trying to learn new
things without opening yourself up to
new experiences without reaching out to
those around you and trying to learn
what their stories are if you spend your
life closing yourself off and never
taking a risk never taking a chance
never taking the opportunity to look
stupid in the faces of those who you may
or may not respect you'll never go
anywhere I would encourage everybody who
wants to do something who wants to try
harder who wants to go farther in your
life to try something new something
exciting something that terrifies you
just try try try try try until you can't
try anymore and then in those small
incremental imperceptible changes that
you see on a day-to-day basis you'll see
a clearer picture of who you really are
and who you could be who you want to be
and then you have no idea what potential
you possibly have inside of you so just
take that to heart because this is a
lesson that I've I'm still in the
process of learning like honestly truly
I'm still in the process of learning Who
I am and I'm still in the process of
learning what I want to do but I'm happy
I'm happy that I get the chance to fail
I'm happy that I get the chance to learn
about myself I'm happy that I get the
chance to be here for you guys I'm happy
that I get the chance to be here with
you guys to make stuff for you to do
stuff with you to do charity efforts
with you to spread goodwill and
encourage everybody
to try something new so thank you
everybody so much for watching next
Friday there will be a special premiere
to do with the tour and we are going on
tour again in Australia if you're in
Australia and you haven't bought a
ticket yet you better hurry they're
almost sold out to go to tour Dom
markiplier calm and see us live we've
perfected the show by now we've
perfected the show it's a really fun
time and this time around we're gonna
have a so much more audience
participation that we've had even in the
past shows so if you haven't gotten your
in Australia go to tour know markiplier
com see me Bob Wade Tyler Ethan live and
in person and with a cool show for you
and maybe maybe we'll pull you up on
stage and have some fun and in other
news there's I am working on the other
projects that I've mentioned before
those are in the works
amongst other cool stuff that I've got
to show you very soon but just thank you
everybody so much for being here thank
you everybody that became a member of
the channel and remember if somebody
does become a member of the channel or
give through super chat and I didn't see
it remember to add their name and check
them out and give them some
encouragement they see that this is
really cool to see so thank you guys so
much for being here I've more
information about all the cool stuff in
the coming few days but thank you guys
so much for watching and I'll have more
stories to tell once time allows so
maybe I'll do a livestream tomorrow
maybe I'll do another one well I'll play
some games and stuff I there's this
really cool game that came out recently
called visages aaggghhhh it's a it's
apparently an unbelievably scary horror
game like a terrifying bone-chilling
horror game so I might livestream that
tomorrow be on the lookout for that
right here on YouTube thank you
everybody so much for watching you have
a wonderful night I'll tell more stories
soon check out the description for all
the other crap that I mentioned and as
always I'll see you bye bye bye guys bye
goodbye how do I end it where's the end
button goodbye goodbye
you